all right buddy what's up what's up
hey
yes uh can you hear me i can hear you
awesome
so uh
thanks to your book um
oh my god look at that
wow
i i read it last year amongst your other
books and uh more more than uh its
weight in gold
it um
i was in a uh
place where
similar to yours
thought about taking a permanent
solution to the temporary problem
and uh
was uh
kind of confronted by my wife that
she want to separate and
she she never went through with it she
didn't do her research
she
makes more than enough and i don't
carry in it down
so basically i i just wanted to do a
share on
the thread of men complicate their lives
and justify why
and
i did my own kind of work
on myself
and
um i had some concussions early in my
childhood that i've
sought out some treatment and i've
according to my doctor they've
rectified themselves
and i'm
so i'm just gonna
talk a bit about that um
so it will basically decrease your
mental health
and sometimes that's gasoline
okay so let me just stop you for a sec
because we're kind of moving around with
some different areas here and i want to
keep this on on point what is the ask
here what is it that you're stuck on
i am uh
sort of
kind of
rebooting and
i'm getting in a place where
from a person who's starting at ground
zero
where do i go to
get back into the game of
making bank
already
for gonna be turning 42 this july okay
so you're 42 and what do you do for a
living
i uh i was a personal trainer but
i started right during the uh pandemic
before it was official
and uh then it was not nearly as um
the revenue wasn't what i was expected
yeah okay so you're back to work right
now like you're working or i'm uh
i i'll be starting work in september uh
doing some actual uh treatment for our
son who's in the spectrum okay for the
summer so are you guys still married or
yeah
sticking it out for the kid
i'm i'm in the thick of it all it's uh
it's a doozy and uh
and it's the train wreck but um so what
is it complicated are you married are
you separated like no we're married
yeah
so the question is how do you get your
life on on track finally
yeah and i come from a
from a
background where
i i finished high school but i
i would always start things and then
stop and start and stop
and um
i'm just
i'm looking for a way out basically and
you want me to provide this to you right
now on this on this quick 10 minute call
this is not this is not hey i'm dating a
woman that's 10 years old do you think
it's a good idea rich like this is a
different different kind of problem this
is a big problem
no but i i was i my
my my whole um
i guess purpose or
i was wanting to put a share where when
men complicate their lives i got married
when i shouldn't have
and that really
brought me to the problems in my life
right now
and
okay so
so what's the plan to unfuck yourself
like what are you going to do to make
money because the thing that you
mentioned early on was making bank so
i'm assuming that you're not happy with
your level of income so what are you
world-class at like how do you monetize
that
my
my goal in the
in the interim i i think is gonna
at least get a job just to keep my head
above water
and then uh
file for separation and then
go into uh
some kind of
uh sales job either auto sales or
that type of thing
you're not playing a win with any of
that
no not in auto sales no
not in any job i mean you're never
really going to play to win work for
somebody else
yeah so i mean like you're asking how to
make some bank but i mean then you're
it's like saying you know it's like when
a chick says that i really like you
aaron but then she
cries on your shoulder about chad that
she's banging
you know you're such a nice guy sort of
thing it's like you know like the mixed
signals like that's what basically what
what is it you're saying is i want to
make some money i want to make some real
money but i'm only going to do things
that are going to make me basic ass
money
yeah i'm
yeah well
need something in in the interim at the
very least and
yeah
um this is this is a lot more than a
quick five or ten minute conversation my
uh uh you know
yeah he said you know book a call with a
rich sort of thing
um
i'm not cheap but i'll i'll make sure
you get your money's worth
okay
okay okay man right thanks thanks buddy
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you